القوانين وكذلك
بهذا الكتاب
اذا نقدم لكم
الثمن ما بامكاني هذا العالم ان يقدمه هنا
تكمل الحكمه
هذا هو القانون الملكي
هذه هي البنود بنود الله
صاحب الجلاله
التي اسست هذا القانون وهي ملتزمه
بالكتاب المقدس وهي تسعى لارساء بيئه يكون
فيها الاشخاص الذين ينتمون لكل الاديان ان
يعيشوا بحريه هذا القسم قسم
الخاص
بالتنصيب هل انت جاهز للقسم
نعم انا جاهز
هل تلتزم وتعد بان تحكم شعب انجلترا
بريطانيا
وايرلندا الشماليه وكذلك الاقاليم
والمناطق المختلفه حسب القوانين والاعراف
انا التزم
واقسم على ذلك هل تلتزم بان تقوم بالافاء
وتنفيذ العدل والرحمه سافعل
بكل قدره ممكنه تقوم بالافاء بقانون الله
وكذلك الكتاب المقدس وكذلك ان تقوم
بالافاء بالدين الذي تم تعديله دين
البروتستانيه وكذلك الكنيسه الانجليزيه
وكذلك كل الانماط المختلفه المرتبطه حسب
القانون الذي تم تاسيسه في انجلترا وهل
ستقوم بالمحافظه على كل الكنائس التي
التزمت وبكل ما تم الايفاء به حسب القانون
كل هذه
البنود اعدوا بالافاء بها وكل ما سمعته
ساقوم بالعمل عليها فليساعدني الله على
ذلك
صاحب الجلاله هل انت راغب بان تعلن وتلتزم
بالاعلان والقسم المرتبط بذلك نعم ارغب
بذلك انا
بكل ولاء في حضور الله اقسم واعلن بانني
مؤمن وانا حسب النيه الحقيقيه المرتبطه
بالبروتستانتيه من اجل اعتلاء العرش ساقوم
بالافاء بكل ما هو متطلب مني حسب القانون